are you both doing good how are you I'm
doing good listen
Congrats on the movie I thought you guys
did such a great job I have to ask the
two of you what is it like the night
before you're doing like a screen test
for this movie how much are you like in
your head thinking like I might be
getting this huge role I'm pretty like I
kind of think things either happen or
they don't happen you know and of feel
like I don't I mean you prepare and then
you don't really have that much control
either they're into you or they're not
really into you I don't know I'm kind of
like well I've done everything I can do
I guess we'll see what happens tomorrow
yeah I mean it depends you know I
usually just yeah you just send the
table you do your homework you know but
when you're just getting closer and
closer it just gets a lot of pressure
and you were like yeah so this callback
I went to was with Linda Hamilton and
they were like you know even if I don't
get the movie I just want to I don't
want to mess it up I don't want to be
ashamed in front of Linda Hamilton I
don't want to you know like I just want
to do my best you know it doesn't matter
think of the movie I just want to do my
thing so it is a lot of pressure but I
think it's also great and what do we do
and that emotion if you don't have that
feeling and that a little bit of fear
when you're on stage or in front of the
camera I think it's part of what we do
and part of the joy of it sure
I believe for both of you this is your
first time making a huge movie on the
scale and being like leads and
everything what maybe surprised you
about the process that you weren't
expecting I think just how it changes
how you need to act which I guess you
kind of know but I'm working on such a
huge scale you just things are such
higher-stakes and there's so much more
urgent and it just changes something in
you where you need to rise to this
operatic scale or else hear this weird
outlier like it just has to be bigger
and I guess I always thought that people
decided to act that way but really the
the world kind of dictates that yeah
it's a different world it's just like
language learning a new language for me
you know it's not a movie at you or an
actor and you going
but you also have to learn all the you
know things of action movement and you
have to make it believable so it is a
hard work it is a lot of work and I was
amazed how you know like it was six
months of really intense you know days
and work and training but you know I'm
glad and I'm thankful and I think it was
worth it
a hundred percent I thought Tim did such
a great job with the action set-pieces
and what I also really appreciated is
how easy they were to follow wasn't this
[ __ ] quick cuts and making you
wonder what was going on can you sort of
talk about crafting these action
set-pieces and maybe again what
surprised you about working with Tim on
them I think he's an expert I mean yeah
it has it's so clear in his mind like he
has it so it's great to have that
captain you know - he was showing you
the previous good he was so clear in his
mind and he was you know he was easy to
actually imagine if things were not
there but we were actually doing most of
the things you know we were hanging
McKenzie was just like fighting and we
were in the truck I mean they were real
you know but I think for me the most
important part of it it was like of
course this amazing visual effects
you'll see they're great but you you
also like team also cared about the
characters you know he also cared about
the emotions and the feelings and that
the characters were relevant and
important to the audience so then you
will care about that yeah I think I mean
Tim had done motion capture and designed
those the fights and the huge set pieces
about a year before he started casting
the movie so by the time he was in
casting he was already showing me that
whole high-waist fight and the the
factory fight with a pre-visualization
of the whole thing with a really strange
stand-in for me and and yeah so he would
always send it to us as he updated it
and as he worked with the stunt team so
throughout the process we had such a
clear view of what we were doing at all
times that we could jump into the middle
of a fight and be like okay well I just
came from there
this person came from here and just
having that grasp on such a what could
be such an abstract thing was so helpful
and I think that's maybe why it feels
clear